donc je vous parlais musique je vais
vous parler concert mais pour commencer
mais je vais vous parler d' écoute dans
l'instrument de musique alors un
instrument de musique vous pouvez tout à
fait l'écho
prenez un violon vous le mettez dans un
champ de maïs
le musicien joue vous écouter vous
entendez un violon n'y a pas de problème
ça marche très bien
maintenant si vous placez cet instrument
dans une salle adaptée pour les goûters
ce violon il va se passer d'autres
choses parce que dans le champ de maïs
vous allez avoir le son direct de
l'instrument qui va arriver jusqu'à vos
oreilles mais dans une salle
vous allez avoir également des
réflexions sur les différentes paroisse
de la salle vous allez avoir un peu de
réverbération vous allez avoir
éventuellement quelques défauts
rapportés par la salle et tout ça va
donner une expression un instrument de
musique qui est essentiel dans son
écoute
lorsque je vous dis là c'est vrai pour
l'instrument de musique c'est vrai pour
l'heure qu'istres c'est vrai pour le
groupe et c'est tellement important que
ça peut même influencer sur la manière
dont joue un musicien par exemple dans
les églises
je sais pas ce que faisait remarquer
dans les églises la musique est
généralement très lente et très
emphatique
parce qu'en fait les églises sont des
lieux résonant vous avez dû le remarquer
et de fait si on se met à me la jouer de
la musique allegro rapide
il ya un mélange des ondes sonores qui
font un peu de bruit ça arrive pour
jouer de la musique
allegro dans les églises mais c'est
assez rare dont le lieu est vraiment
essentiel dans la manière de jouer de la
musique
alors on a beaucoup de chance en france
parce que il ya deux salles qui ont
ouvert récemment des salles sont
splendides
vous avez l'auditorium de radio france
que vous avez la philharmonie à la cité
de la musique qui sont des salles qui
ont été construits pour écouter de la
musique est comme vous pouvez voir elles
sont superbes d'un point de vue
acoustique
elles sont également très marquée demain
d'un point de vue visuel
alors moi je les trouve
vous pouvez aimer ou pas aimer mais
c'est important de bien comprendre que
une salle comme ça pour que la musique
sonne bien bas il faut faire des choix
architecturaux qui sont très structurant
et ça c'est vrai dès le début du projet
il ya un exemple célèbre d'une salle de
concerts aux états unis le film
philharmonique hall de new york qui a
été rasée au bout de 14 ans parce que
l'acoustique n'avaient pas été prises en
compte dans sa conception
ce qui fait que quand je vais dedans
c'était une catastrophe alors ils ont
essayé de faire des des corrections mais
ça coûtait cher et ça marchait pas mieux
donc à la fin ils ont décidé de la raser
ce qui veut dire que faire une salle
comme ça évidemment ça coûte cher alors
il ya ce type de salle donc là vous
voyez c'est la philharmonie on s'est
fait pour jouer de la musique
symphonique
sachez quand même que c'est un peu moins
adapté pour jouer de la musique de
chambre
parce que dans la conception de la salle
on essaie de faire en sorte que tous les
spectateurs entendent bien tous les
instruments et donc on va faire des
choix notamment des choses qu'on ne voit
pas pour renforcer certains instruments
pour avoir cette homogénéité acoustique
donc la musique de chambre
ça va marcher un peu moins bien on veut
faire des corrections pour qui si vous
êtes tout seul au milieu de la salle a
parlé comme je le fais il va voir quand
même vous sonorisé donc la notion de
bonnes salles typiquement on dit souvent
que les églises
moi j'entends ce propos que les églises
ont déjà superbe acoustique
c'est vrai mais dans le cas d'un certain
style des gouttes de musique
pareil pour la philharmonie alors
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on écoute de la
musique d' écoute la musique dans des
stades on écoute dans la liste des muses
de la musique dans des salles
polyvalentes des salle multi activités
et même dans les salles de concerts qui
sont dédiés je pense que vous avez vécu
déjà ce expérience vous êtes toujours
des endroits dans la salle ou à cause
d'un daim
d'un balcon on entend moins bien
certaines fréquences en perdre un peu de
qualité de qualité acoustique
alors pour la musique dans des stades ou
dans ce type de lieu c'est de la musique
sonorisé vous allez me dire c'est pas
très grave
ces deux enceintes on envoie du son et
sajoo oui mais il n'y a pas de raison
que les ondes acoustiques se comportent
différemment quand c'est de la musique
symphonique que lorsque c'est de la
musique du métal par exemple ou du rock
du pop les ondes acoustiques vont se
réfléchir sur les parois vont arriver
vers vos oreilles et ça va donner une
coloration au saut alors dans la musique
sonorisé il ya un autre facteur qui est
un bonhomme qui est derrière des
consoles qui s'appelle ingénieur du son
aurillac ya pas deux heures j'étais en
train de discuter avec un producteur
d'ailleurs qui produit le le compte du
tee shirt que j'ai là qui me disait
connaissez des ingénieurs du son qui
était sourd il se trouve alors il ya de
très bons ingénieurs du son il faut pas
il faut pas exagérer mais il se trouve
que ce que vous entendez un concert ça
peut être dégradée à cause de
l'acoustique mais ça peut être aussi
dégradée parce que l'ingénieur du son on
n'arrive pas à faire sonner la salle
soit parce qu'il n'a pas le temps soit
pas s'y connait pas lieu et qu'il ya des
vraies difficultés à arriver à faire
sonner la salle et notamment tous ses
recoins
parce qu'il va la faire sonner autour de
sa console mais à côté ça peut être plus
compliqué et donc je sais pas si
l'expérience ça vous est déjà arrivé on
peut se retrouver dans un cas de figure
où vous écouter un concert dans une
salle c'est superbe
vous revenez un mois après dans la même
salle et d'un coup c'est moins bon hélas
ça n'a pas changé
donc c'est vraiment un problème autour
autour de l'ingénieur du son alors sur
tout ce qui est musique amplifiée
il ya aussi d un propos qu'on entend
parfois il faut démystifier qui est on
n'a qu'à mettre à fou comme sa leçon
directe arrive à offrir aux auditeurs et
puis tout ce qui est perturbations
acoustique ça passera se passera à la
trappe
sauf qu'évidemment quand on augmente le
son la source les sources secondaires
vont également augmenter au niveau donc
ça corrige pas
ça corrige pas le problème donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve quand même
dans des cas de figure où dans les
concerts baisse le son est un peu fort
je dis pas que c'est à cause uniquement
de ça il ya d'autres raisons
j'explique citerai pas ici parce que ça
serait un peu long mais on est dans une
situation très étrange
aujourd'hui on va dans des concerts et
on se bouche les oreilles jeu
je voudrais vous faire agir quand même
on va un concert on va écouter de la
musique
là je première chose qu'on fait c'est
qu'on se bouche les oreilles c'est
complètement aberrant mais c'est la
situation où on en est aujourd'hui
alors il ya de vraies raisons à se
boucher les oreilles parce qu'évidemment
le capital auditif ces précieux et il
faut se protéger les oreilles mais d'un
point de vue un respect d'une intégrité
d'une oeuvre d'une oeuvre artistique
c'est un peu particulier
alors je vais parler d'un je vais un peu
décalé sortir un petit peu de ces
notions et très technique et parler un
peu plus business
vous connaissez un peu la situation du
marché de la musique aujourd'hui qui va
mieux comparativement à quelques années
ce qui s'est passé c'est internet qui a
un peu révolutionné tous les tous les
usages encore l'an dernier la vente des
disques physiques a encore chuté de 10%
mais bon ça commence à bouger parce que
les plateformes de streaming ont quand
même bien pris le le
le pas et puis vous êtes des
consommateurs qui a acheté votre musique
téléchargée ou stream et ça c'est bien
pour encourager le la culture et puis
vous aussi vous avez changé j'ai ce pas
dans la salle combien vous êtes vous
êtes équipés de casque haut de gamme
j'ai pas à lever la main ceux qui ont
des cas ce que je peux vous dire que il
ya vingt ans quand j'avais votre âge
c'est pas le première dépense qu'on
faisait donc vous avez changé en termes
d'usagé ce qui a changé aussi c'est que
on sent de plus en plus on utilise des
plateformes de l'allée du son haute
qualité parce que le niveau d'exigence à
monter et donc ça c'est un peu aussi dit
même dynamiser l'industrie musicale
qu'il ya encore des choses à faire pour
que l'industrie musicale se porte mieux
et nous enfin on a mené une étude l'an
dernier auprès de 300 personnes 64% des
personnes qu'on a interrogés se disent
parfois ou régulièrement déçu par la
qualité sonore en concert 64% alors
qu'aujourd'hui on parle quand même de
haute définition
vous avez la télé hd mais en concert on
se retrouve dans une situation où on
paye le billet de plus en plus cher mais
potentiellement on sait que c'est une
fatalité d'avoir un son kebab or vous
conviendrez avec moi qu'un concert c'est
d'abord du son certains spectacles on
est content de voir son artiste mais on
va pour un concert pour du son imaginez
imaginer que maintenant quand vous allez
à un concert ou bénéficier d'un son
haute définition
imaginez que vous retrouvez toutes
l'intégrité de l'oeuvre artistique
puisque le challenge est vraiment là
c'est que l'artiste qui arrive avec son
oeuvre
ils arrivent à vous la reproduire avec
toute son intégrité donc vous soyez
affranchi des éventuels défauts de la
salle imaginez que vie si règle et vous
même le volume sonore
imaginez que vous puissiez être votre
propre ingénieur du son c'est à dire que
vous êtes fan du guitariste voulait
l'entendre un petit peu plus donc vous
faites vous même ingénieur du son
eh bien depuis depuis deux ans avec des
amis on s'est posé la question savoir
parce qu'on était toujours déçu en
concert on s'est posé la question mais
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
finalement en concert pour changer un
peu les usages changer la manière de
consommer le concert est ce qu'on s'est
dit c'est que finalement on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer que dans un concert
normal ceux qui ont des casques parmi
vous prennent leur casse le mettre sur
leurs oreilles et bénéficie du sont
sortis de consoles sans perturbation un
son hd qui pourrait être multiples east
qui pourrait être personnalisable
parce que c'est très important cette
notion de personnalisation parce qu'on
est tous différents vous pouvez avoir
envie que ça soit fort faible personne
n'a les mêmes envies alors j'ai
conscience que c'est du ce truc type en
termes d' approche mais et que nombre de
personnes vont dire non jamais je
mettrais un casque en concert pourtant
vous avez des audiophiles aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont plus à des concerts parce
qu'ils trouvent que le son est pourri
vous avez le fan qui lui il y en a rien
à faire qui est du monde autour de lui
lui ce qu'il veut c'est son artiste et
la personne qui a un côté lui qui chante
faux il veut surtout par l'entendre une
grand vide dans sa bulle avec l'artiste
vous avez le technophile qui lui est fan
de tout ce qui règle âge audio il va
s'amuser à régler parce que ce groupe là
il joue comme ça et puis cette autre
groupe là il joue comme ça et moi je
veux que ça sonne ça sonne comme ça vous
avez ceux qui mettent des bouchons
d'oreilles aujourd'hui avec raison qu'il
a pourront régler le volume à leur
audition puis enfin vous avez les
malentendants les malentendants sachez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya 16 millions de
malentendants en france 16 millions
alors il ya ceux qui sont mal entendants
de naissance mais après vous avez ceux
qui le sont devenus
alors je sais pas si parmi vous et les
personnes qui lorsqu'ils sont dans un
cocktail on leur parle ils ont du mal à
comprendre ce que ce que dit leur
interlocuteur parce qu'ils sont gênés
par le bruit
si c'est le cas vous êtes sensible à ce
qu'on appelle le syndrome du banquet et
vous êtes un petit peu mal entendants et
donc dans un concert ce qui va se passer
c'est que même si l'acoustique est très
bonne même si l'ingénieur du son il sait
faire sonner sa salle et que vous
trouvez que le sont ils pas bon ça vient
de vous parce que vous avez perdu
l'acuité pour retrouver vos petits dans
toutes les informations du tiff qui vit
qui viennent sur vos oreilles
alors évidemment on a parlé tout à
l'heure du business de la musique ce
type d' approche sur lequel on essaye de
travailler c'est aussi de positionner
les acteurs de la musique d'un point de
vue économique puisque d'offrir une
manière de consommer différents le mans
le concert c'est intéressant pour les
artistes c'est également intéressant
pour pour les productions pour les
sables qui vont pouvoir trouver le vel
sources de revenus sachez qu'en france
aujourd'hui il ya 3000 concerts de plus
de 1500 personnes chaque année au
comptant de l'ordre de 10 millions de
spectateurs
on estime que ce type de service pour la
profession générés par % au moins un
million d'euros à chaque fois donc s'il
ya 10% personne qui adopte un service
comme ça on serait allé sur des chiffres
de l'ordre de 10 millions d'euros
ce qui commence à être assez intéressant
quand on regarde la volumétrie globale
du du chiffre d'affaires de la musique
alors bien entendu il n'y a pas que
l'aspect business parce que la musique
c'est quand même d'abord dollar et cette
approche là c'est aussi ça s'inscrit
complètement dans une demande des salles
de spectacles jose luis de vous offrir
des shows augmenté c'est à dire ne plus
assister à des concerts uniquement en
tant que spectateur passif mais
potentiellement de vivre d'autres
expériences avec votre smartphone les
expériences de réalité augmentée de
l'interactivité ça s'inscrit aussi dans
une logique de créativité artistique
aujourd'hui quand vous écoutez de la
musique vous avez un droite et à gauche
ça s'appelle la stéréo mais qu'est ce
qui empêcherait que le flûtiste vous
ayez envie qu'ils soient là que le
violoniste il soit là que le pianiste
soit derrière votre tête
tout ça est possible aujourd'hui en
termes d'algorithmes ça existe et donc
les artistes pourraient tout à fait ma
dès à présent offrir ce type ce type de
performance musicale donc voilà on
travaille nous depuis donc deux ans que
je me disais sur sur ce type d' approche
et il s'agit en fait de d'apporter une
innovation disruptive dans le cadre de
la musique au bénéfice de la musique et
au bénéfice de l'économie artistique
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention